look I know it's a sci-fi classic but
I'm sorry I can't even think the title
without thinking Rocky Horror Picture
Show lyrics go on everybody together and
Francis stars in Forbidden Planet and I
will stop singing before I get busted on
copy all right nonsense yeah Forbidden
Planet
I got commissioned to do this one
through the patreon because yes indeed
if there's something you want me to
review that you don't think I'm gonna
get to otherwise you can grab a patreon
slot a commission slot and actually just
make me do it
and that has happened this month with
the classic 1950s sci-fi film Forbidden
Planet this was a film I I did know a
little bit about other than its
reference in Rocky Horror Picture Show I
did know that the story I don't from
what I could find it may never have been
acknowledged that it was actually
intended as an adaptation of this but it
certainly has a heck of a lot of
parallels with the Shakespeare play The
Tempest basically just being set on a
planet instead of an island so if you
know Shakespeare you know I could break
it down for you very easily you've got
your your Prospero and your Caliban and
it's pretty straightforward but anyways
huh
moving on from that it's a really
seminal film in terms of the degree in
the level of the both the narrative and
visually it was a benchmark film in a
lot of ways it was the I might have been
the first sci-fi film that had
absolutely no scene set on earth in any
way whatsoever it had really cutting
edge for the time special effects
had a robot that had a personality that
basically never happened robots would
show up occasionally movies but they
were robotic you know Robbie the robot
has a personality he's a character he's
not a prop that was kind of novel for
the time and that particular robot was
so effective he got reused in a number
of other stuff such as The Twilight Zone
actually a lot of elements from this guy
repurposed for the twilight zone later
on or a cycling Hollywood did it before
it was cool so yeah the thing is it is
1950s sci-fi so you do need to be
prepared for a certain degree of
unintentional camp but honestly as far
as that goes it's not nearly as much as
I would have thought like I do like some
movies from around this sounds like I
like I love actually the Disney film
20,000 Leagues Under the Sea which came
out a few years before this so and this
kind of has that mentality it's not it
has a certain gravitas it's not be it's
not coming across as camp because these
people are don't realize what they're
doing is dumb if it's camp it's only
because it's dated in terms of its
effects and whatnot but overall
mentality and presentation and approach
it's it's surprisingly grounded and the
performance this huh I think this is the
first time I've seen a performance from
Leslie Nielsen before he his career took
the trajectory being the comedic fixture
that he became this was back when he
played it straight and he plays the
commander of the ship so plot wise huh I
should get to that this ship lands on a
planet that there is currently only two
inhabitants on an old man by the name of
dr. Morbius and his daughter and they
are attended to by Robbie the robot and
dr. Morbius is trying to warn the rest
of them off the plan is saying look
there is something here there used to be
other people here they all got killed by
this thing I was never able to stop it
it doesn't come after me and my daughter
but this thing is dangerous you
shouldn't be here but at the same time
he's got all this highly advanced
technology they're like we're not just
gonna leave we kind of need to know
what's going on here you know first of
all we need to figure out your story
because your story doesn't make total
sense and also like this tech we're not
just gonna leave this and then of course
there is also the element of crew of men
who've been in travelling through space
for a while and and Frances you know
being his daughter and being quite
striking and that goes exactly where you
think is gonna go like right down to one
of the crew members literally saying hey
I should teach you about kissing oh that
said it was not nearly as cringy as I
expected it to be
she had a surprising amount of agency in
the whole thing
it was very fairly clear at a number of
points that like she wants to explore
this dynamic relationships with men
she's game for this now there's still a
certain element of skis to it as far as
you know the fantasy of the unspoiled
eager virgin which is basically what she
is and there is a certain amount of like
to just the set up but as far as those
setups go she is not as naive as she
could be
yes she's never kissed anyone before but
she's also learning she's read books she
studied biology she knows the mechanic
so you know she has some base level of
knowledge so it's it doesn't quite have
the taking advantage of a naive person
element as strongly as these sorts of
things can so that was one of those
things I expect you to be real bad and
was just gonna oh no for the time that's
not that bad there's a the actor playing
dr. Morbius guy by the name of Walter
Pidgeon who I don't know I don't know if
I've ever seen him in anything else but
he's he puts him pretty solid work given
that he's has to deliver a lot of
exposition the guys have accomplished
actor he was nominators like twice
before he did this thing and he has to
talk a lot and he has to talk a lot of
nonsense but he has one of those voices
and deliveries that makes it go down a
little bit better and what one of the
hallmarks of 50s era sci-fi is a really
slow burn basically your typical 50s era
sci-fi movie is just really boring for
the hour before a monster shows up and
while this is paced very similarly to
movies that are very boring up until the
monster shows up it's not nearly as dull
and I think a lot of that just has to do
with the actors being of a higher
caliber that I'm used to seeing in this
kind of film and also the production
values being of a higher caliber again
not that high by today's standards but
like I can recognize for when this was
made like no there they're going the
distance with this and so the slow bill
does actually feel like character
development relationship building as
opposed to we got a knock out an hour
before we can introduce the monster
because we only have so much money to
spend on this monster and if we
introduce it right off the bat they'll
see the strings too soon you know which
is the vibe you get from other movies of
the era that you know our sci-fi or
horror and have a monster because there
is a monster in this visualize in a very
interesting way through
basically a form of animation and they
went all out they like they got an
animator on loan from Disney to help
realize this and it might sound really
we're like animated really the I don't
want to say too much about the way that
it's done but I I could tell that it was
animation but it's it's not like it's
Roger Rabbit or Mary Poppins or anything
like that no it's very very carefully
stylized that it works and it looks
otherworldly it looks alien
which is what it needs to if you have a
particular enjoyment or a love of
science fiction in general particularly
space set science fiction especially not
film I think this is something you
should see if only to have an
appreciation of sort of the trajectory
of the medium and of the storytelling
because there's plenty of bad sci-fi
movies you know from around this time
you're playing knives from outer space
and you know plenty of other stuff that
wasn't that bad but like one good but
you can look at something like this and
see how something like this would lead
to something like 2001 a Space Odyssey
which is generally a more of a better
regarded film and honest truth I'd watch
Forbidden Planet again before I watch
2001 a Space Odyssey again controversial
opinion I don't know but it feels like a
very important piece of sci-fi
storytelling history and but one that's
actually enjoyable to watch because
there are often times there are films or
books or what-have-you that like I
recognize are important but I still
don't enjoy there's a lot of things like
that a lot of the important movies like
um do I have to watch this this one I
did enjoy it I didn't love it I'm not
gonna rush out and buy my own copy of it
but
as a lover of sci-fi I feel a little
embarrassed that I hadn't watched this
before I feel like I was missing out on
a piece of the development of the genre
because you can see how this was a
massive stepping stone to what would
come later with things like 2001 so
things like Star Trek the original
series and it's it's very much a
grandfather to those films and the and
that T and those TV shows and those
ideas and it presented them in the best
way they had been presented up to that
point you know not just going others a
cheap-jack genre who cares like no let's
make it look as good as it can and then
people later went huh I thought we can
make it look even better and it's it's
important and it is well presented and
maybe maybe because they ate so much
from The Tempest and if you're gonna
steal stealing from Shakespeare is a
good way to go
maybe that's what elevates the story to
a point that it works better than things
like this island earth or you know other
things from the same era that you know
we're good for the time but don't hold
up this holds up pretty decently all
things considered Forbidden Planet I did
not know what to expect going into this
I'm glad I saw it have you ever seen
this thing do you know what only by
reputation do you know it at all like
does it actually have a reputation
beyond a rock your picture show lyric
whatever your thoughts are something
down in the comments let's talk about it
whole bunch stuff to do down there as
well cuz you know likes and subscribes
and there's a bell I hear it's the thing
to hit that and links to my patreon if
you want to support this help help me
pay my bills and also you know links to
my book social media blah blah blah all
that stuff's down below click on things
they'll the buttons they do stuff links
take your places or don't you also don't
have to because at the end of the day
you're the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]